we're going to begin with
chris livesay in venestia ukraine that
is about 125 miles southwest of kiev
where russian forces destroyed the
civilian airport over the weekend
another escalation chris good morning to
you
good morning tony yeah the air raid
sirens have been sounding here after
eight russian missiles slammed into the
airport president of ukraine volodymir
zelinski calling once again for a no-fly
zone over his country as russian
shelling continues to take its toll on
the most vulnerable and a warning these
images are disturbing
in the kiev suburb of earpin people dash
for their lives
[Applause]
as russian shells rain down
families clutching their children their
belongings their pets making a desperate
escape
this mortar hits a crossing
killing a mother and her two children
in the besieged southern port city of
mariupol
this baby boy is whisked into an
emergency room
doctors fight to save his life but it's
too late
his mother and father sobbing in
disbelief can barely hold each other up
they kiss their son goodbye
a fragile life that should have been
protected by a temporary ceasefire one
that was supposed to last long enough to
let some 200 000 civilians flee
but a second straight day of heavy
shelling slammed that door shut both
sides blaming each other for firing the
first shot
russia is fast resorting to
indiscriminate shelling kharkiv
ukraine's second largest city has
endured days of relentless bombardment
but even here despite russia's superior
air power as shown in this kremlin video
ukrainians continue to repel the enemy
capture its soldiers
[Music]
and even while trapped in bomb shelters
show that ground can be more easily
conquered than the human spirit
this morning russia and ukraine agreed
to yet another ceasefire in keeve in
other cities after previous attempts
there failed here in vineyards the city
where we are where the airport was just
attacked residents are fleeing the
center of town over fears that it could
be next tony
crystal say in central ukraine forest
chris thank you very much